you flip it around for jimmy garoppolo
and 38 other members of the 49ers 53-man
roster
this is their first playoff game ever at
least that they're playing and garoppolo
has been around greatness in new england
but he hasn't played in the playoffs
he's getting the start for the number
one seed there had been questions about
him earlier in the year he answered the
bell in some big games here's garoppolo
from yesterday
when he was asked about making that
playoff debut this week against the
vikings
we've had a couple of uh late games this
season that just felt like playoff games
you know start with seattle here
baltimore new orleans all those games
just um
and we've said it throughout the entire
season i think it's going to help us
going forward obviously being the
starter and backup's a little different
but uh yeah i'm trying to prepare the
same i have this whole season you know
treat this week just uh go through my
routine and everything like that like i
normally do it won't change too much i
think just um you know you gotta feed
off that energy though a little bit
it's playoffs you gotta love it
yeah first playoff start pressure will
be on him and he's faced this vikings
defense one other time that was the
first game of the 2018 season he did not
have good numbers on that day a couple
of weeks later is when he tore his acl
and i don't know that that has any
relevance whatsoever look the bottom
line is this even though he hasn't
played a playoff game he's right
many of the games the 49ers played this
year had playoff intensity two games
against seattle the game at new orleans
the game at baltimore i think that helps
prepare everyone for what's to come
chris i agreed i mean yes i mean how
many we how many times did we talk about
it in the month of december they went
through a three-game stretch that we'd
argue was as tough as any team went
through in the history of football with
those games you just mentioned let alone
like i mean i don't know mike you know
again i haven't seen the guy blink yet i
just haven't seen it so i can't believe
that it's gonna happen this weekend oh
hey brady's suspended we need you to
start the first sunday night game of the
year in arizona oh no big deal he goes
out and throws a touchdown pass you know
oh hey we we traded you to the san
francisco 49ers can you play in like six
days in chicago and get us a win and he
moved around he's he just doesn't seem
flappable that way he is unflappable
he's kind of just
that way i mean hey
oh i went out to dinner with a porn star
oh is that a big deal i don't know i
mean that's just kind of the makeup of
him it seems like you know to where he's
like
that are you talking about him or
yourself no him
um
yeah and look i you said we haven't seen
him blink much this year
there was that one game though the
monday nighter against seattle
late in overtime when the 49ers really
should have been trying to engineer
either hey a last ditch shot at getting
into field goal range or just don't give
the seahawks enough time to do anything
with the ball there are a couple of
misfires from jimmy garoppolo on that
drive that kept the clock from
continuing to run and gave the seahawks
an opening that they took advantage of
and ended up winning the game so
i remember we both were critical of him
about definitely definitely you're right
we were i mean but that was uh you know
a game where listen he was he was under
pressure a lot he did have some good
moments yes and over time was he shaky
no doubt about it but i think from this
point on is when he kind of like we kind
of went okay he kind of answered the
bell every time it rang from here on out
and the last piece of evidence for me
was the last time they played seattle i
mean he went up there and you can't get
more of a playoff hostile environment
than the seattle seahawks and he really
arguably played the best game of of the
year on the road in the biggest moment
so i expect him to play well again and
hey mike the biggest thing is we know
like
it's more than him the support system
around him is good the you know the
coach is good he's had two weeks he's
going to come up with some plays that
are going to screw this vikings team
over and we know they're healthy in
their running game and debo samuels and
george kittle and emmanuel sanders they
got weapons so i think shanahan will
early on will find ways to kind of get
his team going through his great game
planning and things just to make them
feel good and kind of break the ice and
get them going
you said earlier that what vikings
should do to the san francisco defense
is attack the corners and not try to run
the ball down the 49ers defense's throat
what should the 49ers attack in the
vikings defense well i you know that you
certainly can have the same kind of
conversation where oh okay xavier rhodes
outside on emmanuel sanders and and debo
samuel certainly yes we can get into all
of that
uh i think the big thing is mike zimmer
traditionally is going to be all over
stopping the run game and the way
shanahan does run the game the thing i
would be
wary of if i'm the vikings uh and the
way i think shanahan shanahan's gonna
have a lot of plays i think to keep the
vikings off balance early on off of his
bread and butter meat and potatoes type
of plays so you might see some of those
reverses the speed sweeps oh we're not
really running the ball we like to run
the ball like this but oh i'm going to
keep it on play action and have some
great play design down the field so i
think it's like you know that's what you
just got to look at for the san
francisco shanahan a master manipulator
of defenses and things like that if
you're mike zimmer i'd be careful early
and era on saying let's just stay back
play simple rally make tackles let's not
do anything over aggressive or stupid
and get burned for a 70-yard touchdown
i think trusting those linebackers like
eric kendricks and anthony barr to get
to the ball in the running game help
with the coverage of george kittle and
hope that your front four can create
pressure without a lot of blitzes one of
the one of the points you made in the
aftermath of that saints game you didn't
see the staple of the zimmer defense
with the double a gap pressure where two
linebackers are standing there and
they're going to blitz they're going to
drop into coverage it becomes too
predictable one thing zimmer's done and
i got to give him credit right he has
self-scouted himself as you would say
and he's gone back and made some changes
we'll see what changes he makes when uh
saturday rolls around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports